the former CIA director's tweet is
insane to anyone who has a brain yeah
former CIA director Michael Hayden
thinks Republicans are more dangerous
than the world's most violent extremist
groups including Isis Al Qaeda and
Menudo
especially Menudo
it started when British journalist
Edward loose tweeted I've covered
extremism and violent ideologies around
the world over my career have never come
across a political force more nihilistic
dangerous and contemptible that today's
Republicans nothing close to which
Hayden replied because he's like a high
school kid I agree and I was the CIA
director
now somewhere there's an Al-Qaeda leader
going what the hell how many goats do we
need to bang to get some respect around
here
and then there are the goats going
seriously how many more times do I need
to get before Al Qaeda gets some respect
around here
I'm in trouble but remember last week
Hayden seemed to endorse the execution
to Trump remember that so now Hayden
thinks half of America is worse than the
terrorist he routinely killed
if he believes that what would he
recommend here take out the RNC with a
cluster bomb drone strike our nation's
golf courses
and if Republicans are indeed the most
dangerous group a former CIA director
has ever seen then maybe the CIA really
isn't actually protecting us from real
threats
but it backs up what we've been saying
for years if you believe Trump was worse
than Hitler then you could break the
laws to stop him hence the Russian
collusion hoaxes and burying the hunter
Biden laptop
right Sam Harris
whatever scope of Joe Biden's corruption
is it is
infinitesimal compared to the corruption
we know Trump is involved it doesn't
even stack up against Trump University
right Trump University as a story is
worse than anything that could be in in
Hunter Biden's laptop
yeah okay
but it's not just Harris here's skull
face
people that believed that the election
was stolen and have a right to storm the
capital which is a substantial number
people in a Republican party are evil
their people actually racism is evil all
right misogyny is evil
oh there's a stand
after that Carville shed his skin and
ate a mongoose
[Applause]
cat I actually on the five today said
that uh I was wrong and you were right
about the Patriot Act that I did I
dismissed ominous warnings that our
government could do to us yeah you were
you always were saying well everything
to hurt that's not how I sound that was
pretty good that's how it sounded to me
yeah I thought you were talking whatever
women
I appreciate it thank you but I always
I've always known I was right so oh good
for you yeah
um thank you but of course I mean it's
it's that giving people power to be able
to wield in political ways and
especially for them to even make these
kinds of statements I mean do they have
any kind of evidence to back it up yeah
the only thing they pointed to was
January 6th but that was like 2 000
people and it was my day yeah well it's
not quite a majority of Republicans yeah
and it's uh out of the 2000 perhaps 200
I don't know whatever we're idiots
probably more I don't know I don't know
any of them personally so I thought they
were all living with you at some point
in your life Cyrus he
he crazy this guy droned terrorists and
is saying that Republicans are worse
okay this is a compliment yeah this what
is the safest group to talk trash about
and possibly get on TV
Republicans exactly you say that stuff
to antifa and them there'll be some dude
outside your house will do something
he's trying to get the key word here
ladies and gentlemen is former he's out
of a job he's trying to get relevant
heard there was some interest on CNN so
all of a sudden
hey guess who's the most dangerous
person on the planet the GOP
so and then will somebody will respond
by saying well that was really unfair
and unkind do you have any stats to
support that and he will smile and go
that's why you're the most dangerous
person there is because you're going to
come back with things like that and it's
the same thing with the guy who was like
I hate what about isms okay let's say
Trump is everything that he claims he is
does that make Biden's corruption that
less like he only killed Four Guys where
on the other hand Trump killed eight
yeah you're both murderers like that
doesn't excuse what he's doing and
that's how they defend anything but
amazing thing is
Trump's been tried I don't know 75 000
times and he keeps walking away
unscathed he's like the Teflon president
where they won't even put this guy into
questions because of the situation but
again goes back to the same thing he's
out of work he's desperate he says GOP
hopefully somebody like Trump will fire
back on him then what happens he gets on
the show yeah that's it then he bring
him back and he has more expert
and No One's Gonna Hurt Him for it right
about you guys in polo shirts and Coach
shoes
I got to work I don't have time to go
protest outside his house so that's
that's why we do it Jason it's kind of
creepy though that this guy was CIA
director and he had these feelings it
makes you think that there are some
other stuff going on that we didn't
really know about yeah how much more
trust can we lose yeah right and these
two guys you know to tyrus's point
they're hanging on for some kind of
relevance I actually feel bad for him
because you know when they get older and
they don't have those important
positions they want to be in the
Limelight again and they want to say
something unfortunately that's some
crazy rhetoric that he's got going on
and it doesn't do anything to help this
country yeah and you know we need to get
back to positive stuff I don't want to
hear from any of these old fools and I
actually like Carvel he used to be you
know kind of a funny guy he shoots it
straight and he's married he's married
to a republican yeah and actually in
this you know he says that about
Republicans but he also you know tears
down Democrats yeah in this story and
regularly he calls them uh doofuses you
know Coastal doofuses or something like
that so I like a Straight Talk guy like
him but you know this went on for 30
minutes and I don't think any of you
watched the whole 30 minutes no of
course not right so you know I just saw
that for the first time yeah so you know
I I don't even know who you are right
nobody does nobody does good for you uh
you know marvel rock on nobody cares
Anthony last word to you what do you
make of all this it's just their
playbook it's a political it's the
political climate we're mid midterms are
you know a few months away in two more
years we'll be hearing this again this
is what they call Republicans racist and
stupid John Carville calling us stupid
uh James Carver calling a stupid so I
made a list of what I think is stupid uh
pulling troops out of Afghanistan before
you pull out the Americans before you
pull out the Allies spending billions to
hire more IRS agents in the middle of
inflation in the middle of a recession
defunding police why do you think
crime's up open borders don't check vax
cards at the border but yet Djokovic
can't come over and play in the U.S open
that's stupid uh closing the Keystone
Pipeline when we don't have affordable
Alternatives that's just to name a few
that's all stupid
[Applause]
races
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else